One of the benefits of having your Seamoth be bright pink..
..is that it stands out very easily for the reapers to find you..
..in the middle of the night and then eat your brains out through your...BUUUUT!
Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica
Now, in this episode we will be venturing off to the place that we said we NEVER RETURN because death lurks around every corner..
...i-in all honesty, we're going to go back to the Aurora because now that I have the welder tool
I CAN FIX THE AURORA!
...Or at least I can stop the radiation from leaking, but also there is an upgrade in that generator room
..that I need to get to - and it is oddly quiet in here..
..and I think I know why, because when I loaded up my game I went over to check on my fishies and my fishy tank..
..and you may notice there's something missing in here that was a very prominent feature the last time we were here..
Yep!
That's right, the egg that I put in here...is gone..
..Which I can only assume means that it hatched!
- and escaped and is currently stalking the hallways, waiting for me to drop my guard..
So that it can kill and then EAT ME...
*inhale*
So we all have THAT to look forward to..
- but we also have to look forward to the WALL OF HEROES here!
- so I got three new names from the comments section - thank you all for helping out
The first one is 'John Smith'...no relation to 'Steven Smith', who said: "Why didn't anyone tell Markiplier
- that the heated blade can cook the fish?"
I don't know...you're actually the first person that ever said that to me, so you are SUPER COOL!
- Don't think I can actually spell your full name in here...and youuu deserve your own locker
...I don't know what I'm gonna shove inside your locker, but it's probably gonna be useful...
- The next one goes to 'Amir Hossam'...I'm probably mispronouncing that name...but thank you so much
Because you said that I need the terraform to get to the possible cave opening
...and I'm assuming that's the one down, deep below the depths
- so maybe in the next episode, I'm gonna make that and we're gonna go down into the depths..
Of hell.
And last one goes to,  'B-Brendan K Game'..*unable to fit the name in the box*
Gmmm...
Brr-Brendan Kgum
...I'm just gonna...
'Gam'
Brendan Kgam...
...who said "Karen is your only friend on this planet
...make a rusty bucket for her to live in"
- and that one just made me laugh so, thank you everybody so much for commenting
I really do appreciate you guys following along the series
- but NOW, we must venture off!
- Into the abyss!
...in the middle of the night apparently
- b-oh good, it's coming into day.
And
there is the upgrade in the Aurora - there's actually an upgrade to 'The Cyclops'
- which is going to be very important because
I believe
- even though my Seamoth has about the maximum upgrade for its 'Depth Capacity'
'The Cyclops' - I think...I'm not 100% sure on this one - but I'm pretty sure that 'The Cyclops' can go
even deeper than the sea moth
- which would mean that we would have even more to explore
EVEN THOUGH
it seemed like we reached maximum capacity by going to the end of the game,
there are actually
deeper points in the game
with which to see.
So we're gonna find our way there eventually and hopefully NOT die
because dying is something that I've been VERY, VERY good at
- over the past few episodes that I've been playing this
- I'VE DIED.
A LOT.
Admittedly.
- If I was in a real scenario where I was trying to survive
in a horrible - I'm going the wrong way
- on a horrible, horrible, HORRIBLE
desolate...
- where...
Oh! Okay
I was about to say 'Oh God, I'm in reaper territory'
- by the way,  I don't know if I mentioned this but I finally found out the name of the thing
It's called the 'Reaper-Leviathan'
- which is a lovely name...
th-they came up with two different names
to name something horrible and scary and big in the ocean
- and then they decided that they couldn't decide between the two of them
so they named it both!
The 'Reaper-Leviathan'!
So hopefully we can skirt around this..-I can't see th...- WHERE THE HECK AM I?
They did another update and whenever they do an update they change things
and I-
-I coulda sworn I was going in the right direction
and th-
Uhh... Wh-
WHAT THE HELL?!
WHERE DID IT GO AGAIN?
I DID NOT
NO
I WAS MADE A LEFT
Euhhh..
I don't like this.
I'm right in Reaper territory aren't I?
At least I can see the ocean floor again
..so that's awfully nice.
Okay.
Everything's fine
- I'll see you on the inside..
The Aurora.
*ding*
Alriiight
Hey, how's it going sand shark?
- What a doofey doo
Look at you!
- and listen to the lovely rumble
Ok.
Did this get smaller?
..I don't get asked that question a lot shut up
- I'm gonna park my Seamoth in this precarious burning hole in the ship
then fly my way..-I'm going the wrong way..-
- fly my way up here.
'Scuse me
Okay
So in here, there is the generator room
- so this - oh, no, wait, this is not it
THHHIIIS
is
the generator room
So, now that I'm in -THE GENERATOR ROOM
I can take my repair tool -
- which has a good amount of energy to it
- and I can actually charge this up because one of the reasons why I still have these particular fins
is because THIS takes energy
So when I swim with it...
...it actually rejuvenates!
- and good thing I got those first aid kits
- why is this not rejuvenating?
WHY IS THIS NOT REJUVENATING?!
- Oh, there it goes
- It rejuvenates!
So
I gotta find all of the problems with THESE
- and I gotta fix 'em up.
*chimes* Herpedoo peduu
And with THIS I don't need the radiation suit anymore
- which means that I can get the moisture retaining...
*Karen speaking in the background*
- Oh God, ten radiation leaks?
KAREN!
COULD YA PUT 'EM ON A LIKE A MINI-MAP OR SOMETHING?
POP 'EM UP ON MY HUUUUD?
*Karen reporting on repaired structure*
THANK YOU
I KNOW, KAREN.
I'm gonna get you a rusty bucket to live in
- because apparently that's the BEST for my computer-wife
ss.
Wives.
I ONLY HAVE ONE
KAREN
WHAT'RE YOU SAYING?
WHAT'RE YOU TALKING ABOUT?!
YOU'RE THE ONLY LOVE FOR ME, BABY
*Karen reporting on repaired structure*
Oh
*Karen reporting on something being detected*
Is it just me or is she getting sassier?
Sounds like she didn't like the idea of me having other computer wives...
Or
Computer boyfriends apparently in the Cyclops
Oh well.
I'll be back once I get all these welded up...
- Okay, I'm not sure but I think I got all of the breaches that are underwater
- which means that the rest of the breaches either have to be above
- on the upper areas..-I'm just scanning REALLY closely -
AHA!
I SPOTTED YOU!
YOU THOUGHT YOU COULD GET AWAY FROM ME
- BUT I'M GOING TO FIX ALL YOUR PROBLEMS
With FIRE!
The same way I fix all of my emotional problems...
*Karen reports*
*squeals* THREE LEFT?
*Karen sass*
KAREN
COME OOOOON
Okay, I'm gonna look above for 'em
Hopefully
We'll get somewhe-
-There's one!
I knew it!
It had to be true
*fart noise*
There's one more
There's just ONE MORE
So if that ONE SON OF A BITCH..-WHOAAAHHH
HEYYY
It's the son of a bitch -
- I swear these are appearing randomly
Annnnd
I'M AMAZING!
"Drive core breach sealed. Radiation dissipation in 3 days." -
-"Trying download attempt with Aurora blackbox" -
Karen: -vertical containment field restored. Auto decontamination sequence initiated
*Wooing noise from Mark*
NIIIIIIIICE
I'M THE MA-
Karen: -are estimated to return to safe levels in t-minus 3 days
NICE
Karen: -ten hours.
Oh, 3 days, 10 hours
OKAY - Good enough for me
- That means that this will soon
be safe to traverse
And
- I mean, it's already safe to traverse but I also wanted to explore a little more
- I may have already picked up
Th..- I can actually probably check to see if I picked up the
Power doodaddie
Blueprint
I don't know...
- I've got the Cyclops hull...
*dramatic ambiance in-game*
WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT?
HAVE I HEARD THAT BEFORE?
I DUNNO IF I'VE HEARD THAT BEFORE
ERRALRIGHTY THEN
THAT AIN'T GOOD
APPARENTLY..- Okay
..- So I'll be right back once I finish scouring the rest of this place
- Just in case
There's anything that I missed
But this seems...
...markedly different.
- Okay, nevermind
I'm back to where I was so B.R.B
Okay..-AHHH SHIT
NYAHH SUGAR-TITS
*Splash*
Sploosh.
Ehh-I-Oooh
I don't think I've explored THIS area
Oh, that sounds bad
Ooooh I like the rumbling
- it makes me feel very unsafe
Hmm
Huuuh
Okaay
Okay, this seems new
*Strange warbling sound*
- and the music has changed
Which leads me to believe I'm either close to my
IMMINENT DEATH
OR SOME AMAZING DISCOVERY
OR NEITHER AND I'M GOING TO BE VERY BORED WITH WHAT I FIND...
- HOHO
THERE'S NOTHING HERE
YES!
EXACTLY AS I PLANNED
B.R.B!
Okay, so apparently now we're on our own in the blackness
So that's nice...
..-What is thaaat?
Is there anything down here that I should know about?
Probably not
But anyway
The other thing that I need to conquer an-er-in this area...
Is
*Exhales heavily*
The trail of debris...
...that extends back behind the ship
But as..-Oh no
Oh OH
Oh
-Okay..I was about to say "Ah crap"
But the only bad thing about that...
...IS THERE'S A BIG ASS REAPER!
STANDING RIGHT THERE
READY TO EAT ME
So
The thing about that area is that there are tons
- and I mean TONS
Of supplies
There's ... uhhh
Supply boxes aplenty
STREWN ACROSS THE SEABED
Ready for the taking!
- so I need to find a way to get around the Reaper...
- and then see if I can get there
..-where..whoa
Where am I?
Where's...
Where's the goddamn air?!
WHERE'S AIR??
AIR!
OH NO
AIR
AIRRR
AIR?
AHHHH
Karen: Emergency, 10 seconds of oxygen remaining.
AIIIIIRR!
Where's the goddamn air?
I..whaaa-how did I get..-
OH GOD
Please tell me that's water..!
Oh no...
Oh no
Wha-? HOW?
HOW DOES THIS HAPPEN??
OH GOD!!
I SEE IT!
*Screams*
NOOOOOO!
*Screams loudly*
Uhhh....
Huh
Ho..-my God!
OHHHH
I MADE IT!
Hooooooly crap!
I didn't believe in myself for one goddamn second!
I gave up already!
I-I threw in the towel...
I'm a quitter!
I'm a loser, baby!
- but I survived!
Okay
So
I'm gonna get back to my Seamoth, then I'm gonna get back...
*pause*
...to the base
- because there apparently is a gun
That I can craft
There's a gun of some sort..-I dunno if it's a good gun..
The propulsion cannon
Maybe, with THAT
I can shoot things at the Reaper
- and kill it
but I doubt it's even possible TO kill the Reaper
BUT
We shall see...
- It's always..-I don't know why
I don't know how
and I don't know why
but always whenever I go to the Aurora
everything goes wrong and I nearly have a heart attack
Why can't I just have a nice, normal trip to the Aurora?
Where things are fun and happy and filled with DREAMS
Hello, sharkiepoo
What're you gonna do?
Huh?
You wanna mess with me?
You doing back-flips to impress me?
I AM NOT
IMPRESSED
Karen: Welcome aboard, captain.
This..um, *chuckles*
Are ya..-YOU OKAY?
YOU GUYS OKAY?
YOU NEED SOME WATER?
I-I MEAN YOU GOT PLENTY OF WATER
- BUT DO YOU NEED SOME SANITY??
Oookay..
You have fun now...
You-You have fun...
You have fun
Okay...
Bonked my ship all over the place..
Annnd it's daytime
Okay
Gotta get back to base
Gotta get back to the base
*mumbles*
- but I can confidently say
- that I repaired the ENTIRE Aurora
And everything is A-OKAY now
Are you dead?
- oh, you're not dead?
Well you're gonna be soon
BONK
*Laughs*
- sorry...
I'll leave you alone
with a few broken ribs and internal bleeding...
That's just the kinda nice guy I am
I bet I can build this base up a bit more but I'm not quite ready to go farming again
because farming...
...was a bit of a bitch
Well, not really it was actually quite peaceful
Karen: Welcome aboard, Captain
Thank you, baby
Alright so John Smith, you're gonna be my medical man
You're gonna house all my medkits
Thank you for that
- and maybe this power cell and these batteries...
and also this Aluminium Oxide
- and this Mercury Ore
I don't even know what the hell that do
But you're gonna keep it
And als...-
Land..-LAND MASS!?
WHOAAAAAH
BACK UP A SECOND
LAND MASS
*inhales deeply*
Ohhhhhh
OHHHH
Oh
Ohh
OH
OHHH
Land mass...
...everyone said that there was an island available here
And I just got a signal
For a LAND MASS
Which I dunno if you guys know what that means
But to me
That means
ISLAND.
OHH YES
*laughs*
We are in a good spot here
Also I noticed you need to eat a variety of food, so that you don't just eat only of one...
...because if you eat too many of one type of food you will get sick
Plain as that
- and I'm gonna put my last whole fish into my
LITTLE AQUARIUM
- I killed and ate all its friends
but it gets to live with the memory of that betrayal
With new friends that it cares nothing about
Okay
BE FREE
What if I just dropped the cooked -
- What if I just dropped the cooked fish in here with the rest of 'em?
Oh that'd be so sad
Oops
I ate it...
NEVERMIND
I ATE IT
And apparently I ate the raw one too
Well, SHIT
I didn't mean to do that!
I meant to set 'em free!
But I forgot to drop it and instead I ate it...
So, anyway..
That's all the time that I got for this episode of Subnautica
In the next one, we are going to investigate where that land mass signal goes to
and maybe... just maybe, find us an island
so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always
I will see you
In the next video!
Buh-Bye!!
[Outro Music: Crazy La Paint By MiniMusicMan]